هذا أمر مهم على بعد أيام قليلة
من المحاكمة ،
ولكن منذ البداية كان
هذان المحاميان اللذان كانا يرأسان
الفريق ،
حيث كانا يتطابقان جيدًا مع ترامب ،
لا ، لم يسمحا لي بقول آه كايتلين
كولينز وعملت على هذا معًا
و  أه لم يكونوا كما تعلمون ، يُعرف بوتش
باورز
بأنه مطلق النار المباشر
، محامي أخلاقيات كتابي ،
لقد تحدثت إلى الديمقراطيين
والجمهوريين في ولاية كارولينا الجنوبية ،
وجميعهم لا يملكون شيئًا سوى الاحترام
لقوات الجزار
التي لم يروه  كرجل رابحة
رأوه للتو
جمهوريًا دافع عن جمهوريين آخرين مثل
الحاكم السابق مارك سامفورد أو
نيكي هايلي
عندما واجهوا قضايا أخلاقية
لكنهم جميعًا قالوا لي انظروا أن دونالد
ترامب سيكون له محامٍ عظيم
في  بوتش باورز ، قام بعد ذلك بتعيين فريق من
أربعة محامين آخرين
بما في ذلك المرأة التي غادرت لتوها
الليلة أه ديبورا
باربيير وكانت قريبة جدًا من التعريشات
ولديها أيضًا نفس النمط السياسي
يعتمد على أه ربما ليس حتى
كميل للجمهوريين مثل المتعثرين ،
لذا فإن السؤال التالي الذي ستطرحه
عليّ بشكل صحيح هو
لماذا لا نجيب على ذلك بالضبط ومع ذلك ،
نعم ،
لا نعرف إجابة ذلك حتى الآن أنا
ذاهب إلى  تكهن أنه ربما كان ذلك
بسبب محادثة مع دونالد
ترامب
قيل لي من قبل مصدر خاص بي أن
هناك شيئًا لا يمكن الدفاع عنه هو
الكلمة التي تم
استخدامها ولا أعرف ماذا يعني ذلك
ولكننا سنواصل البحث للعثور عليه
فقط للتوضيح ، تم إخبارك بأن
هذا كان متبادلاً
بشكل جيد ، نعم إنه كان قرارًا متبادلًا
ولكن في كثير من الأحيان
عندما يتم طرد الأشخاص أو عندما يتركونك
تعلم أن القرار المتبادل
هو نوع من لغة العلاقات العامة التي لا
نعرفها  ولكن يبدو لي أنه عندما يترك محاميك ،
فهذا يعني أنك ربما أردت
أن يغادر محاميك ، لذا سنضطر إلى
معرفة ما
يعنيه القرار المتبادل ، وأعتقد أن ما
يعنيه بالنسبة لي هو أنهم يحاولون
التحايل على هذا الأمر
وجعله  تبدو أكثر
رشاقة
مما هي عليه بالفعل